I gotta have a baby now every time I got
have a baby I don't even know like I
don't know if I had my eggs work I don't
know I don't want to have a baby but
everybody's like you gotta hurry up
because if you don't you be in your 40s
a baby gonna be handicapped and I'm like
well the baby's going to be handicapped
I don't have to tell you I'm not first
of all I'm gonna love that baby even if
it's hit I'm gonna a song I love that
baby yeah a thousand percent plus it's
gonna come with a handicap sticker we
can walk away if we want I understand
why would I
I gotta go you guys would wait thank you
so much oh sweet
[Music]
hi sir hi hi hello hello yes ma'am
hi how are you I just want to make sure
you know where I'm going
totally programmed in the GPS right now
should be there in 22 minutes oh okay
great
well the app said that you're disabled
so I just want to make sure them with
all due respect to you I prefer the term
hearing impaired and I wouldn't take
pity on me ma'am you're a 3.5 on the app
I'm a 4.8 I'm doing you a favor by just
driving it right now listen okay I'm not
trying to discriminate against you the
app says that you're deaf and I need to
make sure you get me to my destination
on time I have a gig it's not the Stan
do you know how to get there ma'am if
you look at your profile on the app
you're a known water-bottle thief and a
phone charger see who are you the FBI is
this blacklist I can't hear you what oh
don't play that game with me can't hear
you I'm deaf don't play with me
oh man that's amazing
y'all ain't heard I said yet I've
been sitting in the back man listening
to what you guys been laughing that and
I appreciate the fact you guys are a
progressive free-thinking crowd that
doesn't see color I'm black ladies and
gentlemen
I just need y'all to know that up front
or else my jokes ain't gonna be funny
Zander's get that out of the way I went
onto this car this bus stop I went out
okay right here this bus I am you can't
take the bar I'm are you kidding me you
don't tell me I can't take the bus Rosa
Park you want to get out
get out I'm no longer responsible
is wrong with you
[Music]
don't look at her don't look at him
that's not Elaine at me would you like
to sit down please take my seat there we
go
what are you doing what what are you
doing why would you put a stroller on a
seat like that and it's woman's trying
to sit down the baby needed a seat
okay he's in a seat he's in a stroller
why wouldn't you give her a seat this is
Harriet Tubman
she fought for this why do you care so
much you broke ass Beyonce Beyonce sang
lemonade she drank it all okay how cute
I have diabetes
I was not cute that little camouflage
like people can't see you
really yeah can you stop it you could
rat you hood rat and baby forever what
about your queen hood right look at
yourself and me look at a dusty ass way
you a mess girl and all three of the two
pox on my shirt is praying for your
edges how about that not gonna help well
I did this for you
all y'all mama tried you okay how
about that oh look at his little bitty
backpack hike it up hike it up a little
baby pack bag full of people wrong taxi
I'm from the south and so I walk on the
outside of the sidewalk you all know
this chivalrous custom you know this
right as to protect the woman in case
the car jumps the curb I'm strong but I
ain't that strong you know what I'm
saying
but I still walk on the outside because
they're like oh I was oh you're such a
gentleman
little does this woman know that the
real reason I walk on the outside of the
sidewalk and so the juice from the
air-conditioning won't hit me on my face
that is disgusting
[Applause]
[Music]